the App Store is especially lit because
Wiz Khalifa is about to drop his very
own mobile game entitled Wiz Khalifa's
weed farm so it's kind of like Farmville
if your farm had to smell like Portland
so it gives gamers a glimpse of what it
would be like to grow and sell weed
without having to disappoint their
parents take it from wins himself who
says it's a fun game and I play it all
the time it's better than Pokemon I'm
going to see it again and again please
if you wanted to be Pokemon why don't
you just make a game based off smoke
come on
all the polka stops are park benches
wherever you can buy a gas station hot
dog
now since Wiz Khalifa has gotten the
ball rolling what will the next
controversial celebrity video game be
Felicia Kendall Jenner's Pepsi challenge
[Laughter]
[Applause]
there are no winners in that game but I
have did Tyler Perry presents a very
Madea ghost Protocol yes Steve bannon's
Chuck hunt all right boy